-Our next guest
is the lead singer
of the iconic rock band The Who.
He can be seen
in the new documentary
"Rock Camp: The Movie,"
which is available now on
all major streaming platforms.
Please welcome Roger Daltrey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes, my man! Come on!
That's my man!
-Hey, Jimmy.
-Roger, welcome back
to the show.
You know, I love having you
on the show.
We've been very lucky
to have you on.
Thank you so much.
The last time you guys came on,
we did
a "Classroom Instruments."
And we did
"Won't Get Fooled Again."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, dear.
Jim, now, I've got to tell you,
the Roots,
they're one of my favorite bands
of all time.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They're fantastic musicians.
-We've been called --
-I got to say,
I've never had so much fun
singing that song
other than the first time
I sang it on the record.
That was fun.
-Wow.
-But doing it with the Roots
on those instruments,
that was so refreshing.
It brought it back to life.
It was fabulous.
I absolutely loved it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And thank you, guys.
You were fabulous.
-We've been called --
Tariq calls us
the Dream Team of late night.
[ Laughter ]
I'll let him have that,
but we are.
But obviously, The Who
is an iconic rock band,
but you as a lead singer
of the band,
not only your singing
but your fashion,
but also your -- the swinging of
the microphone.
That is iconic, and no one else
can do it without me going,
"That's Roger Daltrey."
When did you do it first
and go like,
"Well, that could be my thing"?
-I did it out of pure boredom,
actually,
because I was on a stage
with two maniacs
and a very straight bass player.
[ Laughter ]
And I just got bored
and I thought,
"I've got this thing in my hand
that I'm fed up
with holding up there.
What do I do with it?"
So I kind of threw it
and held on to the cord.
And, of course, it came back,
and I thought,
"Well, that was interesting.
Let's see what more
I could do with it."
And I went on to be quite good
with that thing.
I mean, I could take a cigarette
out of someone's mouth
from about 20 yards,
which is quite good, you know?
-Oh, my gosh. That's crazy.
-Yeah, I was a really, really
good shot with that thing.
But I can't see it now,
of course.
-Yeah, well, no.
-I throw it up in the air,
and I just pray
that it comes down somewhere
within that kind of --
-So it can hear
your voice somewhere. Yeah.
Is there an earthquake
where you are, Roger?
[ Laughter ]
-No, we don't have earthquakes.
Oh, it's my foot on the camera.
[ Laughter ]
-Stop doing that!
Don't do that!
It's not your thing!
-Oh, no, no!
[ Laughter ]
-No, I don't want that
to be your thing.
-It's Moon come back
to haunt us!
He's in the next room!
[ Laughter ]
-Do you remember --
You obviously remember
"The Smothers Brothers"
when you guys went on to
"The Smothers Brothers" --
he put, like, explosives
in his drum and blew up
the drum set live
and didn't tell anyone
on TV.
-No, that was -- it was planned
for a little bit of smoke
and the skin was going to break.
But Moon being Moon decided
this wasn't grand enough.
And I think he got
the pyrotechnic man drunk
with a bottle of brandy
and talked him into putting
about 10 times the amount
of powder in the cannon
that was supposed to be there.
And it was literally like
a hand grenade going off.
If you look at the film
and you study the film a bit --
you can see it on YouTube --
you see Pete banging his head.
And Pete is about 10 feet
from the drum kit.
And he's patting his head
like this.
And what he's trying to do
is put his hair out.
His hair is on fire.
[ Laughter ]
-We have that clip.
I want to show everyone.
Here's The Who
from "The Smothers Brothers."
Check this out.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God! Oh, my God!
Yo!
That's the greatest clip ever.
Yeah. I don't know how --
I just love you guys.
I want to talk about
"Rock Camp: The Movie"
because I loved it,
and obviously, you know
I'm a fan of rock 'n' roll.
And I think everyone,
in the back of their minds,
wants to be a rock star.
You know, and I think
this rock 'n' roll fantasy camp,
you go like,
"Wow, that's interesting.
I get to jam out
and meet these icons."
And you just get to
sing with Roger Daltrey.
What made you say yes for
the first time in doing this?
-I said yes mainly, well, first
of all, I got invited to do it
for a charity thing for Levon
Helm, the drummer of The Band.
-Yeah, absolutely.
-And I was a huge fan of Levon,
and I just wanted to meet him
and tell him --
'cause he just got over
throat cancer.
And they were doing a fundraiser
for him.
So I decided to go along
and have a look.
What it did for me was remind me
of all the reasons
why I did this
in the first place.
I did it because we were young
and we were having so much fun.
And we were just fans of music.
Simple, very simple living
and playing music.
We'd do anything
just to play music.
And I was with people of
varying abilities of playing,
some very good, incidentally.
Some of them extremely good,
but some of them [Laughs]
extremely bad.
-Yeah, of course.
-And it makes it fun.
It's good to be reminded of
where you started.
'Cause we've been around
so long now,
I feel like we're the wallpaper.
I mean --
-No. No.
-And it's just good to be
reminded that, when we started,
how simple, and how -- we were
just doing it for the music.
We didn't know how far it would
take us, and look where we are.
-Yeah.
-It's wonderful.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You'll never be the wallpaper.
Yeah, that's my man!
Roger Daltrey, the one and only!
"Rock Camp: The Movie"
is out now.